groups thank you very much for the kind
introduction and for inviting me and for
organizing this great workshop so this
talk is based on joint works with Chris
and Nick in my above jinda 30 militia
cough unwrapped and day in front will
have sky out and they will mainly talk
on one work of some subset of with some
scepter of these authors but I've also
briefly mentioned some reason without
was not a subset of these authors and so
this talk will be about algebraic proof
so essentially we are interested how
hard is it to prove at some point less
than some specific variety and that also
tells us something about GCT because by
the end of today if you have a
multiplicity of structure you have
proven that some point is not containing
some orbit closure so there has to be
some equation that vanishes on this
orbit closure by the point of the vanish
on this equation right you don't have to
write this down explicitly but it exists
and so I want to talk a little bit about
these connections but just will be like
to talk before more down-to-earth so
we'll really be able to prove something
but only rather tiny things so that's so
and it starts with some algebraic
variant of this natural proofs and so
maybe you're all natural no natural
proof but it just will briefly tell you
something about it so this is an excuse
why we are so bad at proving lower
bounds and so the boolean setting is was
done by that's possible all from jülich
and we have some property P of boolean
functions we call it natural if it's set
of satisfies these three properties here
and I should mention that so I so
compared to the original paper
I flipped so PA please P by the
complement of P this is because in the
boolean setting it doesn't matter right
because if you want to flip 0 and when
you just do the negation operation but I
would want to talk in the algebra Endre
as bad as a back setting and they have
zero and nonzero and there's no
algebraic operation which switches
between these two things and so it's
better to look at it in this way
and already also set the parameters to
the most
most upsetting here so we have to the
usefulness so if I whenever I have a
function that easy to compute which
means poli-sci circuits then it should
have this property and should be
constructive so as a give you the truth
table of some function you can decide in
poly-time in the size of the proof table
whether it has this property or not and
it should be large you know what you
have this largest condition so random
functions don't have this property with
some probability and then first of all
most or almost all of the lower bound
techniques there are natural there they
have the Euler can they have natural
properties and then red porphyry go on
and essentially there out is this very
result so whenever you have a natural
property it can distinguish between a
pseudo-random function having poli-sci
between a pseudo-random function having
poly answer circuits and a truly random
function is the exponential time and the
conclusion is if you believe in some
variant of public key cryptography then
no natural proof control super for
normal circuit double bonds and
essentially the question is so now we
have an explanation why we are bad at
proving boolean lower bound so we need
also an explanation where we are better
at proving at your bragg lower bound and
so one of the problems of course we
don't have any concept like a one-way
function in this algebraic setting and
so therefore last year so they were
essentially two independent papers one
by four book and fork and the other one
the grocery Kumar Saxon xerath and they
introduced this algebraic natural truth
essentially I always want to have this
to set up here so I have some set M of
monomials and I look at the linear span
of this monomers that will be my ambient
space so you could think of M being all
the degree D monomials so look at all
these monomials
or aluminum wheels for every variable
stick degrees bound by D so this is and
then I also have some some Class C
inside the span of these monomials so
you should think of C being say
some easy polynomials or instance have
polynomials having poly size sockets and
then I will have some Class D and then D
for every monomial in my set M I will
have one variable and essentially you
could think of I want to take me the
coefficient vectors of my polynomials
and see I want to plug them into D so
therefore you can so this actually D
will tell me something so when a DS 0 or
not will tell me something about whether
C is hard or not TM SaLuSa variables so
for every monomial there's a variable
which are simply called T and I will
index simply it with the monomial that
you could also say this T 1 T 2 T 3 T 4
and so on and I just number the manami's
for 1 2 3 4 and so on it's just a
notation so what I want to do at the
coefficient of the monomial and a
polynomial from C I want to substitute
this for the variables T M so that's why
I have this notation and then some
polynomial D and my class decent algebra
d natural proof against this class c if
d is the nonzero polynomial and for all
F in my set C D of F vanishes and this
means if I take the coefficients of F
and plug them in for these variables
here then the polynomial 0 essentially
and now if you say if I would say if you
think of C's stays VP and you have a
algebraic natural proof for repeat and
you can take a polynomial you take the
COFF inch list you plug it into D and if
it doesn't vanish you know that your
point norm is not in V P so have proof
will know about
the vanishing ideal and of course if you
have a nonzero element adventuring idea
this is what we are also good failures
that is what you're saying yes it's the
same it's just more it's a it's a more
concrete yeah this is the original
definition essentially taken from the
paper from folks we can fork access you
get lashes for free not because they
have a polynomial and two nonzero
elements is always an open set so almost
all the elements don't satisfy your
property and force now you won't have
some barrier and so the way this
barriers was formulated by those two
sets of authors which are was with 16
cheating sets so and you all about
hitting set is and so 16 tearing set is
not following so I have from my
polynomial of magma Class C and that my
my class II again and then H is a C fact
including set if H is contained in C and
H viewed as a set of vectors of
coefficients of length M as a hitting
set for my class D for a class of my
proof
this means that it is at 4d that can be
written as the coefficient vectors of
polynomials which come from from a
declasse that's the situation then from
the definition it's almost
and from the definition you'll already
get essentially this this barrier other
sort of 16 cheating set barrier so tech
are no algebra idea natural proofs
against the Class C even only if there
are no folks and hitting sets fergie
allow say you can set it off set
parameters so for instance if your n
capital n MD so you look at all the
degree D monomials and essentially
there's no algebraic poly and D natural
proofs against this class see if there
are no poly and DS exciting set for five
circuits and anti variables and you can
even special specialized it even more so
if you just for we P it will essentially
say this so you for VP would also have
these poly N and then pollyannas poly
lock in the number of the big variables
and for VP so you could this is a
conjecture and we shall fear now that
there are no poly log and 16 cheating
sets for poly answer circuits but we
don't know that now so this is the
current if you assume this then you
can't prove there are no natural proofs
which would pull our bonds again sweepy
one of the to write the mark by
directional person if and only if all
right
but of course it's not clear so at least
no it's not clear whether these taxing
tailings that should exist or not so
then for Chilika invoke their day for
models where for simple models where we
also know lower bounds there proof
essentially a defects in tearing sets
exists so therefore you can't have so we
definitely can't have these natural
foods and so the our motivation was now
since we don't know how plots of those
conjectures can be replaced this by
something different so can we even
replace it but something more plausible
and essentially we just buy a somewhat
changing the game a little bit so this
original motivation came from tens of
rank so you have notice for tens of T
has rank one if you can write it as the
tens of protocols we went to Center then
the tens of rank is the smallest number
such that you can write the tens of T as
the sum of our rank one tensors and s
also capital s are really no T here this
will denote the set of all tens of rank
at most hour then you can essentially
play the same game so you can all ask
what are lower bounds can you prove
lower bounds for tenza rank with this
justice equations and so you could say
and now that the game somewhat changes
because you could also think of T being
a trial in your form so again have
polynomials but now you don't have a
jump in the number of variables so when
the previous we had n variables and the
proof set exponentially many variables
and here essentially the proofs only
appointee normally many variables so
that's the difference in the difference
in the game then you could say so
led is a poly km and natural foods
against set SR if D is non zero D
vanishes on the set of all rank are
tender and these computed cyber policy
circles
[Music]
natural proof against his class in good
news so the good news for me because I
want to proof with a negative result is
that 10 the rank is np-hard which was
shown by you on ha start a long time ago
and even better so even much harder so
sheet off and independently chef and she
Thank You which deplete that it's even
as hard as the existential theory over
the corresponding field of the field of
Finance at NP complete but it's to see
lot of rational numbers then it says
here as the existential theory over the
rational numbers for three-dimensional
tenses yeah the baptists of course if
that is that s our is not a zero set of
polynomials and Wendy when issues on s
hour then it also vanishes on is closure
and then XR it can only describe the set
of tens of border and get pounded by our
therefore in particular is XR has to
contain some tendrils of rank R because
otherwise stands the rank and border and
would coincide and then bad news now ISM
we don't know where the border rank is
np-hard and we tried for some way to
prove this but we failed and therefore
when you don't can prove anything you
just modify the game so we looked at
some different at some different
quantity which patch which is motivated
by some machine learning and then
network coding applications which we
would call the completion rank order
than sort of the generalized matrix
condition problem so essentially here we
have given M matrices you can think of
this being the slices of a tensor this
is the gander of a problem or temblors
and so the completion rank of such as
instance of matrices is the minimum
number of R such that you can find scar
or scalars lambda 1 to lambda m and you
look at this linear combination here so
you always have to take the matrix a 0
then you can take at an arbitrary linear
combination of the other matrices and
you want to bring the rank below are
whenever you can do this the minimum R
for which you can do this is the
completion of this tempo you can also
think of turn phrasing this in terms of
an ephod linear matrix so therefore
matrix and the end
linear forms and then you're asking how
can I of in CNC at my variables such as
director of below yeah and it was will
foot really between these two these two
statics and this has a motivation from
machine learning is also called the
Netflix problem so we are really working
on something relevant here for the
finesse is that Netflix problem so
essentially I did this Netflix problem
you usually have a matrix and so I don't
have a Netflix I don't have a Netflix
problem because I don't have Netflix my
kids say we have a Netflix problem
because you don't have Netflix so that's
why it's called the Netflix problem
essentially essentially you can think of
in the you can think of having a
partially filled matrix and you want to
fill the entries such that individually
from each other such that the rank of
the mix becomes very low and to the
entries that you know that user a which
is rose and you have two columns which
are of the film so user a likes user B
and then it flicks s we making we are
doing making billions of dollars with
that content so users have to be really
simple minded and this is reflected in
the case that the rank is no of this
matrix so that's so this is why this is
called the Netflix problem basically any
Netflix problems you such a single since
intere just so these are just the matrix
is here we which has just one one in
some position and there's a where or
everywhere but just very natural to look
at this generalized problem
really yeah but you can't do so
so these fix the positions where you can
change right a metrical digit you have
to find the positions where change such
as the rank drops but here the positions
where you can change are given to you
they might be even connected to each
other it's related but not the same and
how can we know first this so we can now
look at the following since we take all
these matrices you take all the scalars
and so if you look at all these these
things here such that the rank of the
savviest bounded by R then this is a
closed set because indeed can describe
this by the vanishing of the R plus 1
times R plus 1 minus so this is a
variety and we did notice by p.m. in our
and of course to get the object that
were interested in this would be all the
tenses of of completion rank R so you
project away scalars lambda 1 to lambda
M and this gives you the set of all
[Music]
terms of C that have completion link
bonded by our button fall so
unfortunately this set is not closed so
there's no easy examples of for instance
let's do this one so you have this is
your 1 matrix 0 you have to take this
matrix and you can edit this matrix
freely freely to this one but no matter
what what multiple of this matrix here
to this one you always have rank 2
matrix but if you know work with
approximations so you can approximate
this matrix here by that matrix just
think of epsilon being small and then
you add 1 over epsilon of this matrix
here and you get that matrix and this is
a rank one matrix now because if you
multiply the first row by epsilon you
get a second row so you can approximate
this infancy which has completion rank
two by instances which have completion
rank one and this is
repletion nuclear enclosure whenever
general principle this also NASA risky
closure and to for therefore we need to
look at the closure here too and but
there's one caveat how to take the
closure there's some subtle things we
have to be careful of what if you take
the closure with respect to the wrong
ambient space you will get some
meaningless results so here's a very
easy example
so take B be any rank one matrix and you
know this is the identity matrix of size
n by M cell if you look at this example
here you have to take this matrix and no
matter what multiple of B you subtract
you can drop the rank by at most one
this is basic linear algebra but if
you're not working for proximation you
can approximate this low rank matrix B
by this high rank matrix so this is high
rank but if you now subtract this here
from from that you get a matrix which
has rank one so you can by approximating
low rank matrix by high rank matrices
you can drop to drew just a drop from
completion back to border completion
language can be arbitrarily high and
that's maybe not nice and so therefore
we take the closure with respect to this
this space here so we want to
approximate these matrices B here only
by matrices that have ranked not larger
than the rank of the matrix itself it's
not so nice but it seems to be necessary
we take the closure here in this space
here and this variety here where this is
just mean so this is the set of all n by
n matrices whose rank is bounded by row
and I long to our M an order the ranks
of our matrices a1 2 am in our instances
but I will also letter talked on there
are some ways to get rid of that and now
we can define a border completion rank
and so this is all the instances here
and now we approximate our where we can
approximate our matrix is a I here the
matrix is a I tilde and the rank of a is
bounded by the rank of AI
and we can find rational functions in
epsilon such that the rank of this thing
is bounded by off but is not about
accomplishment so we approximate so we
have polynomial approximation to the
matrices and rational approximations
reference and continuous constants and
the whole thing should be bounded by our
and this is what you call the border
completion rank and that essentially you
can also take the Euclidean closure in
the in the ambient variety that we have
defined and there were general
principles will give exactly the same
same quantity
and it's only what we now can show is
that deciding born a completely blank
that's an np-hard problem so we couldn't
show this for 10 the rank but deciding
for border completion rank is np-hard so
we can we understand Bala essentially
that well that we can prove NP hardness
for this I can also write this as know
about of a closure what we do you mean
by the group is not so nice in
particularly I don't know whether it's
reductive because you need some fi
problem so you can't change this first
matrix so you have generally left/right
actions but what you want to three F if
you think of a 10-0 from two sites you
can multiply with GL n matrices but from
desert and the Sutter rectory can only
multiply with GL n matrices which keep
the first slice fixed multiplied just
like an ethnic group yes so I don't I
don't know what it dispenses reductive I
have don't have a convex I don't have a
comic sample but it's not clear but also
that of proof that it is and so how can
you so how can you prove this hardness
so you can have a self completion rank
it's easy truth and it was also known
and so we give you did use from to CNF
set so of course said it's too thin
after disabilities it's of course in P
as you all know but if I give you a
bound and aspartate can satisfy at least
be of your crosses that stone np-hard
problem and so the you reduce from this
and the instances will be very very
simple so essentially all the matrices
they will just be to I do they will just
have two by two blocks on the diagonal
so there will be a super simple instance
which allows us to control the
statistics border this this limit
process and still get the NP hardness
let's first look at the completion
length because the construction for
border completion rank will be similar
so when you have a cloth CI which is a
literal l1 at the literal a to den or
gadget will simply look like this so we
have so think of this being on the on
the diagonal so on the diagonals we have
1 minus L 1 and 1 minus L 2 and L 1 is
say X K if the literal is positive so
this is 1 minus XK see I'm standing here
if the literal here's the positive
literal and it's just an 1 minus XK so
there's just an XK standing here if the
little snaring a negative and there's
that easy to see this matrix has rank 2
unless you said one of the variables
such that the literal becomes 1 because
then would either have a 0 or 0 column
and the rank drops that's Rowdy
essentially hardness proof from yeah so
you now you put everything on the
diagonals and it's very easy to see by
what except so if the border completion
rank is bounded by 2 as minus B where s
is the number of variables sorry s is
the number of clauses then this is if
not only if the B clauses of Phi can be
satisfied and we don't need any variable
get you to you because you can't drop
the rank if you said something nonsense
like 2 or pi PI squared over 6 or
something like this two variables you
won't drop the rank so that's
essentially lost variable whenever you
do this
the nice and the nice thing now and
about his instances is is that they are
super simple so you have if you just go
back if you just look locate this matrix
here so essentially there's just one
variable standing here there's one where
we're standing there so in every row and
every column there's only one variable
standing and all the one fear they go to
the you matrix a zero now so all the a12
all the a12 am sorry matrices that you
are free to choose
they are just diagonal matrices with the
property that and only one end matrix
has nonzero entry in one diagonal place
so for every whenever you look at a
place on the diagonals there will only
be one matrix which has a nonzero entry
there this makes everything super nice
because we can now go on and essentially
we do if you now has a formation to
these matrices here then you can
essentially find invertible matrix SNT
and they don't change the completion
rank such that this transformed instance
here is exact in the matrices a1 280 and
only approximate in this matrix s 0 so
that's the crucial property and then you
can just do this by if you take duties
approximations here you just do a wrong
kind of operations to clear everything
off the diagonal and once you have clear
to stand by this rank restriction you
know that this matrix is exact and
because the diagonal places there's only
one element on every diagonals from one
matrix this clear and doesn't interfere
with each other and this essentially so
we have the approximations we can make
it almost exact you only approximation
you have any entries in this in this a 0
and then essentially the same proof the
same proof works self works for for
completion rank now offer work for
border completion rank if you look
One Direction almost direct for some
perfectly frank and otherwise now if you
have some some lambda I and this cannot
be rational functions in epsilon so this
D I can in particular be negative such
that this this rank is bounded by 2 as
minus B then the claim is that this also
induces an assignment on Xin to the two
literals LJ such that I can satisfy be
clauses and if you now look at this and
we stay essentially to have rank one if
this locally should have rank one now
then this l1 should we move this one
here and it should that introduce any
negative powers of Gibbs by epsilon yeah
because I'm yeah only on the diagonal
there can be negative powers of SEP
salon that a they can't cancel out so
once you have introduced negative powers
of a trial on essentially you have
wasted your variables and you can't you
can't you could improve on the
completion rank by taking some useful
values to this this is a center to the
main idea and once you have done you
have done it we call a closed epsilon
satisfied if l1 and l2 is of this form
and if you have this epsilon set aside
classes you can say epsilon to zero and
you get an assigned partial assignment
to some variables which satisfy big
classes and to all the other values you
don't know but you don't care you can
sell anything there you make it some
civil one assignment and in this way you
can see that they're also the border
completion right problem is np-hard
so which the mayor so do you did your
main properties essentially these
instances here they are so simple that
you can control the arrow and that most
amendment assume a property
and now we can look you can look at
algebraic proof for the border
completion rank we have to 10:30 and
algebraic poly and natural proof for the
border completion rank for some tens our
team for the completion and further of
some 10:30 being greater than our it's a
polynomial P such that P when issues on
all tenders of border completion rank at
most R P is computed by a poly SCI
circuit for simplicity it should be
constantly because I don't want to and
yeah I want to guess the circuit later
on and I don't want to remove the
constants now and an additional problem
so it should be a proof 44 wanted P of T
is nonzero
new thing that I want
and so what I need us so what the ideas
I want to get the proof and I want to
check what I dreaded when issues on this
is variety here but I don't Lotus
variety but I know a dense set in this
variety and it's then set it's a set of
all chances of completion rank bounded
by our but I want to efficiently
generate this set of terms responded by
completion rank R and essentially I want
to do this by by some polynomial I won't
have attends all the entrances are
polynomial and every when I look at this
just ten zero when I substitute
arbitrary values for the divers in the
polynomials I want to get all the
tenders of completion ranked bounded by
our and how do I do that
well it's very easy to generate say all
the matrices that have been found that
there are because we just take so this
is this thing is a generic rank one
matrix if I sum up role of them and
enough substitute values for all these
variables I get all the rank or rank at
most flow matrices I could also get rank
matrix of rank lower than that
and now to generate all the sensors that
have bought a completion rank bounded by
our zero I just take here these these
constructions that I have here so now I
have matrices Q 1 to Q T which have some
rank if I R 1 to R T which are given by
my origin instance and now to have more
a completion rank R 0 I want to have
some matrix R 0 here and when I and
should be able to subtract these
matrices here from from whatever I feel
to read something which is R 0 yeah and
in this way I get a tensor and which has
polynomials entries under the map the
image of this map will be all chances of
completion rank of yeah of completion
rank our R 0 and what's this good for so
I can
she will be given by my instance so I
will have looking at n by n by T tensors
and it will simply be given by by the
instance this is just a parameter so
this is essentially now the main result
so for infinitely many n here are some m
and some tens or a half the size n NM
and some value are such there is no poly
and natural proof for the fact that is
complete border completion i crawfished
ends up on the PR unless co MP is a
subset of X there is P P P particular
point um a time hierarchy collapses and
how do we do this essentially we want to
prove so f of we have a formula Phi in
to CNF and we want to prove at zombie
and we want to prove that every
assignment satisfies at most B closest
of Phi and this is a Co NP hard problem
and we want to do this and there is P P
P and how do we do this so assume for
the contrary that for all for almost all
N and for all M and for tens of T and
for all values are there so poly and
natural proof and then we take out of
this fee will construct the tensor in
the hardness proof and then we get a
stylus gets a circuit C of size of
polynomial size computing some proof P
and then we need to check that P when
ishes on the set of all ball chances of
power completion rank but this we can do
by using polynomial identity testing
because we have test is just Paulino
this Universal tens of G here which is
the tensor with polynomials as entries
but the image generates all chances of
completion rank are in particular if
this polynomial P when it is on all the
chances of completion Eggar it will also
the value that you get out of the
hardest tools
how much they did it like ooh and Italy
because if it's greater than 10 so I
don't do the completion rank of some 10
so he can be at most n because it's the
rank of the matrix that you can build
and then this B is now whatever for
whatever regime to CNF testing is the
np-hard so I forgot to exact I forgot
exact number at some comfy but you can
really compute it right but nothing
which you don't do you know it in
advance it's a constant times n for some
constant smaller than n yeah and so you
you just take this this tender and you
just check the polynomial identity
testing that is zero and this is what
there is for is for guessing the circuit
this is be VP for the identity testing
and then you just have just another
identity testing influence you just have
to test with a P of understand that does
not vanish and if yes we accept this
find otherwise we reject and so this is
now Adair is PPP protocol for Co MP
complete problem and therefore we have
this inclusion yes and so have you
believed that a polynomial time how it
collapses then for this problem you
can't have for every tenth of G and so
on you can't have as a partnership rules
or proof of polynomial size
try to understand language now does it
say every nonzero polynomial vanishing
ideal of those one of the tensor is
fixed it's not know I tend only only for
specific terms of there's a sequence of
tensors such that no for this plus
specific tenderer you can't have a poly
size proof but of course the equation
the variety could have easy equations i
can't rule that out
we can also write if there's no be
closure problem we could write it as no
big clover it's not too hard the problem
is so the group might not be reductive
and the closure is taking some variety
not in some vector space so it's maybe
not so nice but but the good news is and
some some very reason paper not not
online yet somewhere we can also look at
the homogeneous very end of this problem
so we are now also allowed to take a
multiple of the first for first term
matrix and of course allow it
you have to rule out it should be non
trivial linear combination now you don't
want take all 0 then the rank is 0 but
it's not interesting yeah so it leads to
two people it's projective now you look
at in the projective space and this is
also np-hard also checking whether it is
this we call it now the mini I can do
this bottom in rank problem this is also
np-hard and the closure has taken with
respect to a vector space now it can be
written as nor with closure the group is
now dat normal group that you let act on
tensors in particular is reductive and
the other nice properties were
generating tens of these orbit closures
they also described by these symmetries
this is exactly the ideal setting that
you want to have energy CTR set and in
particular what move Falls from this is
also that for these tenders so you all
bit closure containment problem is
np-hard unfortunately we don't stay
didn't our preprint like this it falls
directly but we don't say they
explicitly so if by chance someone is
reading it currently so keep it in mind
right so so I think it's very remarkable
in view of Cape Town stock
during the sexual yeah of course we try
to offer to make it work for the
obligatory intersection but we don't
know it doesn't work for for the
techniques that we have its containment
it's hard intersection we don't know
it's not the intersection started easy
yeah for a while I thought it would be
easy but there are some very subtle
things that can happen and it's not it's
not not not easy to prove a little bit
all of time so let's speed up a little
bit maybe I'm through half of my slide
so it should it should work relation to
ten Tabata ranked so far so this is
essentially the theorem that Houston's
very easy to proof with them so how it
is completion rank and and rank are
related so if these things here rank one
matrix is then essentially we have this
relation between rank and completion
rank so the rank of this corresponding
tensor is the completion rank of this
tensor plus M this is essentially used
and if this heart is proof by chef and
faith uncle which friends instead simply
use this one and we wanted to use this
for for bottle rank unfortunately we
failed so one reason why we failed is
that we only get Disick where this this
side of the equation or the other one
and the other reason why we failed is to
have two ways these matrices have to be
Rank 1 and Daniel all of a sudden you
get some solutions in the border which
you don't want to have and did that
messed up everything but what we could
you do with this is we could prove that
the similar techniques that attends a
rank is np-hard to approximate within 1
plus epsilon for some constant epsilon
independently that was also proven by
some woodruff and so most likely these
two names are pronounced differently but
I don't know how offer with some
woodworking song and also Joseph
Sinofsky
which was maybe I saw him yesterday ah
he was sitting gay ok great yeah and it
was very funny so I remember it was
early 2000 I went back on the train but
if you one have dirt from overall fat
and then he told me oh it would be great
to know that ten the rank is empty how
to approximate but it's so complicated
and this approximations can do such so
much thing cuz they're tender and now it
took or something like fifteen years and
all of a sudden we have three proofs
just three different books at the same
time that's what it's for the proof
butter so uh so probably we didn't know
of each other so there was nothing which
somehow stimulated is proof so this
proof okay the day essentially proof a
stronger atlas result but I'm the ETH
and this is a paper which has more than
100 pages and this is somewhat in
appendix H or something like this so I
didn't check it - I just had a quick
look at it
you're the proof is its then we reuse
the different construction now so there
it's a I don't know what what symbol and
somewhat similar but Volvo somewhat okay
just them yeah so to get you flour for
active 2x2 caches not to get just look
like this well it's just a little bit
more complicated to just skip this yeah
but what I want to just in the remaining
three minutes I will turn from want to
look at some try example like Christy
ended but which is a very meaningful so
I want to look at this variety is a 10
and said n is the variety of all
matrices does that tell us a variety of
our metal cells were added standing here
with Thurmond 0 okay look at its variety
and then there is similar to what we did
before you can prove that set and has no
well if said and would happen we p 0 a
natural proof then P to the sharpie
would even be contained and they're
asleep
this somehow quite you would expect a
summer what because of that n is a
hypersurface
is described by the equation permanent
equals zero permanent is irreducible now
so the only equation which you could can
describe this variety are just powers of
the permanent multiplied for something
and then this is very similar
construction like before if you would
have to proof you could guess them you
could verify that they vanish on this
this permanent that you used to self the
usability of the permanent for to do
this and then you could get a circuit
for a permanent by using heart often
factorization and then you could get if
you have to circle for the parameter and
you can prove that P to the sharp is
contained in there is P P P so they're
very similar proof you know if the
polynomial America collapses then there
are no we p 0 natural proof against the
permanent
variety on the other hand okay you could
it's a large in a finite field but then
you don't get yes and taluk so you just
take say say the rationals but we want
to be able to compute modulo P for this
construction to work now I don't
generate a random matrix of what I do is
essentially I look like before I have
some polynomial and this point owe me a
matrix here this just describes all if I
substitute in values I get all the
permanence all the matrices that have
permanent 0 but to describe it I need
any circuit for smaller permanence I
used to sell food usability and you do
the step several times to get to get
just the same so I don't except it's
somewhat different but only because I
use yourself the usability but the idea
is exactly the same just the
construction is a little bit more
complicated because I've used we have to
use it several times
that goes to concentrate free yes of
contra 3 0 cos 3 circles because I want
to get you need want to get them and you
want to deal with concentrate you need
to remove so just one thing that I want
to say is that also we we don't have an
actual proof you can get another current
abstraction in a GCT framework for for
the statistic use for for this variety
so um we'll be running out of time so I
mean what is the group action that we
have so we have the action is Adam oh no
Meah matrices that will act on and just
keep the problem fixed or the 0s of the
permanent is fixed by the action which
is monomial matrices and now they're the
only point is so now what do you say
essentially can do this um we look at
this thing here so the problem is of
course they're caught in a drink yeah
because the prominent vanishes on this
variety just by definition and if you
just look at at this so these are just n
such as M one sentence just a length one
if a look m at this 10 disagree
essentially describes a permanent and so
this is just a compact description is
GCT framework of the promenade
so this is the presentation yes the
permanent and just have multiplicity 1
and if you look at Norma closure of some
matrix a then the multiplicity of 2
Sigma 0 if a is and a has permanent 0
and otherwise its 1 and in this way and
them no and all the drinks are waiting
outside and this way you get in this toy
X this again a toy example but you get a
chorus abstraction for your slide so
still you have to evaluate the permanent
we don't know how to do this but you
have compacts by the simple
representation and this treaty friend
you just want to conclude sex
one question it's not let's tag Marcus
again
[Applause]